from the very early days my realization
around the longevity of
twitter newsletter podcast anything i
did was that content was eventually
going to be automated like ai is going
to replace all written content
video content like it's just as ais get
better and better people are going to be
able to produce all the things i write
via ai there's probably already an ai
that will put things into neval's voice
and like write an evol thread without
him writing it so that the content will
already exist what you can't really
automate is personality and the feeling
of connection and affinity that you can
build with someone and so my perspective
from the early days was i want to build
a personality and a connection with my
audience a community with my audience
that they just care about the things
that i am finding interesting and so
that has manifested itself in a few ways
one my newsletter i don't have like a
specific thing i write about i write
about things that are capturing my
interest that i find interesting that
i'm learning at any point in time and my
newsletter is really a journey of things
that i'm learning along the way my
friday newsletter in particular is like
five things that i found interesting
during the week that i'm gonna be
sharing similar to like what tim ferriss
did and i think did a really good job of
it's like [ __ ] the five bullet friday
idea i'm gonna share interesting things
that i'm learning on the journey
similarly with twitter recently it's
manifest itself and like i'm sharing
more content on fatherhood on parenting
on my like journey around wealth and
what wealth means to me and what enough
means to me recently i've done a lot
around like health and fitness something
totally off the path of like normally i
write about growth and productivity and
you know self-improvement etc and well i
was like well self you know
self-improvement health and fitness is a
huge part of that to me and i really
care about physical training i really
care about recovery stuff i like and so
i started posting you know things about
my like workout routine or mobility or
runs that i'm doing and it resonates
with some portion of my people and
they're building this level of
connection with me in a different way
and that has been my perspective is like
i'm just gonna share the things that i'm
getting excited about if people aren't
excited about those that's fine i'm not
the guy for them but if i can build that
like depth of connection with a smaller
subgroup of the people that do follow me
where they want everything like anything
i put out they're like oh i got to be
going and doing that running workout or
i got to go build that habit that style
is building that's cool and that's what
i really want long term and that's what
i think is durable long term hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye